this video was made possible by hover
set up an email address or website with
a custom domain in about two minutes for
10 off
at hover.com wendover
on thursday may 3rd 1979 31 million
221 362 voters gathered at polling
stations across the united kingdom
to decide on who would fill the 650
seats of the house of commons
now any election is important but this
one
held particular significance over the
years leading up to it
the country's manufacturing industry was
collapsing inflation was wreaking havoc
on the economy
mass strikes were plaguing both the
public and private sector
unemployment was exploding and it was
quickly becoming clear
that britain was losing ground to japan
germany
the us and other subjects of post-war
economic booms
margaret thatcher and her conservative
party proposed a solution
they would curb the power of unions cut
personal income tax
and privatize nationalized industries
essentially
it was a complete rejection of the
economic ideology
of the prior 30 years however in the
view of the british public the status
quo was what got them to the turmoil of
the era
so thatcher's message resonated once the
ballots were counted
the conservative party picked up 62 new
seats
bringing their total to 339 a majority
and therefore making margaret thatcher
prime minister
of the united kingdom the era of british
privatization
started quite quickly first with british
petroleum
of which thatcher began selling off
shares just months following her
appointment
but then in the new decade the trend
kicked into high gear with british
aerospace
british gas rolls royce british airways
british steel national express british
telecom
british leyland the british airport
authority and
dozens more state-owned enterprises
being sold off to the private sector
by the 1990s the concept of a
state-owned enterprise was becoming
increasingly obscure but there was just
one major sector that the sell-offs had
yet
to really touch the railroads
thatcher herself didn't dare touch them
politically it was tricky in the country
trains operated at a
loss to many rural areas from which her
party needed votes
fully privatizing the industry would
mean that those areas would inevitably
lose service
and the conservative party would
inevitably lose votes
in addition in her view railroads were
just one of the rare examples of sectors
that just
had to be publicly run they were just
too tricky to run
both efficiently and effectively with a
purely profit-seeking motive
her reign ended though in 1990 after a
leadership battle within her own party
and her successors weren't so cautious
conveniently in 1991 the european union
acted first it issued directive 91-440
which read quote
whereas the future development and
efficient operation of the railway
system
may be made easier if a distinction is
made between the provision of transport
services
and the operation of infrastructure
whereas given this situation
it is necessary for these two activities
to be separately managed and have
separate accounts
essentially what this said was that the
companies organizations or agencies that
actually operated the trains had to be
legally separate entities
from those that operated and owned the
tracks upon which trains operated
the reasoning stemmed from the eu's wish
for private rail competition
against the government run systems they
were opening the door for companies to
operate rail services
on any track in the european union as
long as they paid for it
of course that gave the government a
perfect first target for privatization
on april 1st 1994 rail track
came into existence a private company
that now owned all the tracks
stations and rail infrastructure in the
united kingdom
there was much work left to do though
british rail's trains went to three
newly formed rolling stock companies
their telecoms infrastructure was sold
to raqqa electronics
freight operations were split up and
allocated to six newly formed private
companies
and this process went on and on and on
but then came the question of passenger
train
services it was very clear that the
solution to privatizing those
would not be a quick and complete
sell-off
the crux of the problem was exactly what
thatcher had identified when she decided
not to privatize the railways
the public had come to expect and rely
on inherently
loss-making rail operations while
running an 8 am train from edinburgh to
london
may be profitable running a 1pm train
from manchester to buxton
probably is not in order to run trains
at the prices
to the places and with the frequency the
public demanded
someone had to at least sometimes take
a loss with that a structure
evolved inter-city british rail's
long-distance brand
was split into seven segments network
southeast which primarily operated
commuter services in and around london
was split into ten while regional
railways
which operated short distance services
throughout the rest of the country
was split into eight these 25 train
operating companies
would at first be owned and run by the
government but through time
the operations of each would be
franchised out to private companies
now each of the train operating
companies were designed so that their
advantages and disadvantages
were in the view of a private company
somewhat
balanced that's rather important since
any franchisee is contractually required
to serve certain stations at certain
times
and certain frequencies for example the
intercity east coast franchise
includes the super high demand high
frequency east coast service from
edinburgh waverly to london kings cross
two of the busiest train stations in the
uk between which any operator
should be able to turn a profit however
this franchise also requires
for example the operator to run at least
one train a day that leaves london
king's cross between 11 30 am and 12 30
pm
and eventually calls at the small
scottish town of kingusi
along with a corresponding southbound
service that calls up the town before
arriving at king's cross between 5 30
and 6 30 pm
now only some 108 people use kingusi
railway station
each day most to get on the regional
trains running between glasgow or
edinburgh and inverness
a private company likely would not
choose to service a station where they'd
be lucky to pick up a dozen passengers
in a day
so the intention of the franchising
system was to balance
things out put a little bit of the bad
with the good
so that places like kingusi would not
lose their service
to further balance things out the
government would accept bids from
companies to operate the different
franchises
and what the government would receive
could either be in the positive
or the negative the government would
look at all the serious bids
and quite simply pick the one that would
make them the most money in incoming
franchise payments
or lose them the least money in outgoing
subsidies
on the surface it seemed like the
perfect system
the free market would force companies to
compete to win a franchise
and in the end the government and by
extension the british taxpayer
would spend the least amount or earn the
most amount of money possible
but that's just the view from the
surface
if you dive in and take a deeper look at
the franchise agreement
the contract between an operator and the
government cracks
begin to show this document is the draft
of that agreement for the intercity east
coast franchise
the one that includes edinburgh to
london service published by the uk
government during the latest tendering
process in 2014
it begins with definitions of terms a
statement of governing law
and assorted other legal declarations
but then moves on to exactly how the
relationship between a franchisee
and the government will work for example
in schedule 1.1 part a section 4
it lays out the idea that franchisees
cannot alter the timetable without a
long arduous process of consultation
with the government
and other stakeholders including the
public section 7
established the requirements for
operators 2 on average have the capacity
for anyone to find the seat immediately
upon boarding and off-peak trains and
within 20 minutes of boarding for
on-peak trains
section 12 introduces the concept of
breed performance levels which if a
franchisee exceeds
will put them in breach of contract for
example the intercity east coast
franchisee must not exceed
0.0235 cancellations per 1000 miles or
1600 kilometers traveled in its second
year of operations
and by the end of year 10 if their
franchise even lasts that long
the level must be down to 0.0119
schedule 1.2 part a section 6 lays out
the requirements for alternate
transportation in the event of train
cancellation
this section outlines the requirements
for timetable publishing and poster
display
stations this one defines the operator's
data reporting requirements
this one outlines the requirement for
operators to accept folding bikes on all
its services
and full-size bikes quote wherever
reasonably practical
this establishes the prohibition of the
franchisees engaging in any business
except for the operation of trains and
certain auxiliary services like selling
food on board
this outlines the franchisees ban on
entering into any leases without
government approval
and leases for stations depots and other
facilities that it's required to enter
into
and this section summarizes what the
franchisee is legally required to help
with for the operation of the queen or
subsequent monarchs train
so the government tells franchisees
where they must operate
when they must operate which trains they
must operate
which facilities they must lease the
maximum amount they can charge
how long they can operate so the
question is with very
very little ability to choose how to run
their trains
where are they supposed to compete
the answer is the bidding process
that's essentially the only step in this
process
where free market competitive economics
come into play
but these forces pushed bidders to over
promise
and under deliver they'd say they
expected a certain number of passengers
translating to a certain amount of
profit leading to a certain hypothetical
future franchise payment
the main number that the government
looks at in a bid
if those passengers didn't appear as
predicted then the profit didn't come
either and the franchisee would fail to
make the payments upon which
it bid this is a cycle that happens time
and time and time again gner
owned by c containers was the first
operator of the intercity east coast
franchise
before it overbid in its renewal failed
to make its payments to the government
and lost the franchise early to replace
them
the government awarded the franchise to
national express in 2007
who would operate the services under the
national express east coast brand
however just two years later it emerged
that they
too had forecast more passengers than
emerged in reality
were not able to make the payments they
had bid on and so they lost the
franchise
in 2009. after this experience
the government temporarily
re-nationalized the railway
under the operator of last resort scheme
that had been set up for this exact
situation
the succinctly named east coast company
owned and run by the government
operated the line until a new bidding
process was opened in 2013.
a joint venture between stagecoach and
the virgin group won the bid
and operated services under the virgin
trains east coast brand
it turned out that passenger and
therefore revenue growth
had not matched the levels they had
based their bid upon therefore they were
hemorrhaging money
therefore they could not make their
franchise payments to the government
therefore they lost the franchise in
and once again the government
re-nationalized the line
and operated services under the london
northeastern
railway brand throughout this nearly
25-year cycle
only one period stood out from the rest
between november 14
2009 and february 28 2015
when the line was run by the
government-owned east coast train
operating company
things went well
in its final full year of operation it
was time for fourth among 23 train
operating companies in terms of overall
passenger satisfaction
fifth for punctuality fourth for values
for money
and even while being one of the most
popular train companies
it generated over 1 billion pounds in
profit over the years
that went straight back to the
government and by extension
the british public therefore when it was
announced that the franchise was to be
re-privatized
many asked why why should the government
hand over a well-run
well-liked well-profitable company to
private hands
which will at best just take a portion
of those profits away from the british
government
and people over the following years this
and other related questions doubting the
merits of this almost entirely unique
franchise model
grew louder and louder by the start of
an increasing number of railways stopped
operating under the franchising model
instead they were run as concessions
where the government contracts a company
to operate trains while taking the
financial risk themselves
open access operators where private
companies simply pay for track access
typically on the most lucrative routes
without any additional agreement with
the government
or the operator of last resort model
such as with the east coast franchise
where the line is renationalized and
government
run simultaneously it was getting
tougher
and tougher to find new reputable
bidders for franchises up for renewal
many were extended through direct awards
where the government skips the
competitive bidding process
which goes against the original vision
of rail franchising
all around the viability of the
franchising model
was coming more and more into question
both domestically
and internationally where complete rail
privatization
was something few countries had even
considered let
alone implement it like with so many
things though
march 2020 dealt a death blow
to the united kingdom's privatized
railroads
with the onset of stay-at-home orders in
britain passenger numbers fell
through the floor and became very clear
very quickly that no franchisee would be
able to fulfill
their obligations to the government
therefore
after years even decades of debate on
whether the railroad should be
renationalized it just happened
in a day secretary of state for
transport grant schnapps
issued a letter to parliament stating
that all franchises
would immediately be shifted to a
concession model
the government would pay all their costs
plus a small management fee equal to no
more than two percent of the company's
costs in the year leading up to the
pandemic
under any definition even if private
companies were operating the trains
this was a nationalized railway
originally this was to go on only for
six months
just as a temporary measure but in the
final days of that period
on september 21st another announcement
was made after 24 years
rail franchising as an operating model
was done forever
now as of yet it's not known exactly how
the country's railways will operate once
the provisional recovery measures
lapse the most we know comes from the
transport secretary
who said in the initial announcement the
model of privatization adopted 25 years
ago
has seen significant rises in passenger
numbers but this pandemic has proven
that it is no longer working our new
deal for rail
demands more for passengers it will
simplify people's journeys
ending the uncertainty and confusion
about whether you're using the right
ticket
or the right trained company it will
keep the best elements of the private
sector
including competition and investments
that have helped to drive growth
but deliver strategic direction
leadership and accountability
passengers will have reliable safe
services on a network
totally built around them it's time
to get britain back on track
now there has always been and will
always be debates
on whether the privatizations of the
uk's railways was a failure
it brought the highest number of
passengers onto the rails in the
country's history
higher even than during the golden age
of rail transport in the early 1900s but
it also brought
by most measures some of the highest
fares in all of europe
it increased the public satisfaction in
the railroads and brought it to one of
the highest levels in europe
but counter-intuitively it also pulled
the government's rail subsidy
up to its highest level in history quite
decisively
after privatization the decline of the
uk's rail industry
turned around for the better but it's
not clear
is how much of that can be attributed to
the privatization itself
rather than the increased focus that
privatization brought to the rails
what is clear though is that the
experiment itself
failed improving the resilience of a
franchising model
despite positive public sentiment about
the railways as a whole
an overwhelming majority of the british
public supported
renationalization therefore it did not
start a domino effect of rail
privatization
across europe and the world it did not
convince the general public in its
merits
and it proved most of all that the model
was fundamentally flawed
as it only worked in the best of times
and the worst of times
will always eventually come while the
privatization
and deregulation of the air transport
industry for example
rail's most direct competitor is almost
universally viewed as a success that
brought lower fares and industry growth
to the point that state-owned airlines
are now largely a relic of antiquity
the same cannot be said for rail no
country
has really cracked the nut of fully
privatized
passenger train service in the 21st
century
while many have taken half measures such
as privatizing freights
the rails awarding concessions to
private operators but taking on the
financial risk like the uk now does
or even doing as the uk did before and
effectively fully privatizing railways
none have landed on a privatization
model successful enough
for other countries to replicate its on
mass
so even if the uk's privatization
experiment accomplished
some of its goals it failed on the most
elusive one
it failed to convince the uk public and
the world
that the privatization of railroads was
the best path forward for passenger
train travel
in the 21st century
what the past year has proven time and
time again
is just how important digital presence
is
having a nice clean digital presence is
getting to be almost as important
as having a nice clean physical presence
whether you're still in school or in the
big scary world of employment
this still applies and one of the
quickest and easiest
ways to improve your digital presence is
with a custom domain from hover
even if you don't want to build a
website just yet it's worth getting one
for three main reasons first you can
direct it to your linkedin
youtube twitter or any other page so
when you share those with someone
it's just one simple link second you can
set up a custom email address at that
domain
which just looks and feels so much more
professional than one ending in that
gmail yahoo icloud or something else
and third domains are going away with
every minute
so if you want one that corresponds to
your own name company name or anything
else
it's worth getting now before it's gone
hover makes
all of that super simple and quick they
help you find super unique domains with
their over 400 extensions
their pricing is very transparent and
fair and best of all you can get 10
off and help support this channel by
going to hover.com
wendover so professionalize your web
presence
and get your domain before it's gone for
10 off once again
at hover.com wendover